hey everyone and welcome to biology
professor make sure you subscribe so you
never miss one of my study videos also
make sure you see the link in the
description box below which goes to a
folder of free study notes totally free
and what they are is they are the
pictures in pdf format of all of my
finished whiteboards so if you want a
picture of this board with all of the
notes filled in for study purposes just
check out that link today we're talking
about how does bt insecticide work
now if any of you are gardeners or you
know gardeners you may be familiar with
bt insecticide and what i think is so
cool from a biology perspective
is that we see
we see a lot of things that we learn
about in class things like selective
toxicity and protein structure
and cell signaling and receptors and so
we're just going to jump right in
i'm going to do this lesson in three
parts i'm going to tell you what bt is
i'm going to tell you it's mechanism of
action that really answers this question
how does the bt insecticide work and
then i'm going to explain why it's
totally safe for humans and you know i
put it on my tomato plants and then my
kids eat my tomatoes and it's no big
deal so very very very safe as an
insecticide
okay
so what is it well bt insecticide first
of all is the most common
biologic
pesticide globally that means that it is
a biological entity it's not a chemical
right it's not like ddt or something
like that
bt
actually stands for
bacillus phtharyngensis and if you've
had any kind of microbiology training
you're going to recognize that word
bacillus bacillus thuringiensis this is
actually
a bacterium
naturally found in the soil and so maybe
you're thinking what we're spraying
bacteria all over our crops and maybe
that totally grosses you out but it's
okay
you know a handful of fertile soil
contains more bacteria in it than there
have ever been humans living on the
planet earth
ever like in the history of earth okay
so there's so many bacteria and soil
anyway totally natural no big deal so
bacillus thuringiensis that's the
scientific name of this bacterium
i'm just going to call it bt for the
rest of this video
now bt produces
toxins
these toxins are proteins they're a kind
of protein and they are called toxins
because surprise they are toxic
in certain circumstances
so these toxins are toxic to developing
insects again totally safe for humans
totally i'll explain why down there
each bt strain remember we're talking
about bacteria so each strain of this
bacteria
targets
different
insect groups so there are strains of bt
that are toxic for this group of insects
and don't hurt any other insects and
there are different strains that target
these insects or these insects or these
insects
and it depends on the strain
which
insect groups they will be toxic to
now
there are about 200 give or take
different commercial formulations so
commercial products
these are non-toxic to birds they're not
toxic to fish
excuse me
because each bt strain targets different
insect groups you can get bt that will
target those pesky hornworms that are
eating your tomato plants i have
personal experience with that
but that are not toxic at all to
friendly pollinators so you're like not
going to hurt your your bumblebees right
that are coming around to do the
pollinating
um if you want to see like my my
particular experience with this issue i
do have videos on tomato hornworms where
i talk about what hornworms are and how
to get rid of them newsflash bt and also
a really cool video where i found some
baby tomato hornworms they were like
practically microscopic i could barely
see them
but i got some really cool video images
of that or video images videos
so take a look at those if you're
interested now let's talk about the
mechanism of action so
how do you
use bt insecticide well it is applied to
the leaves of crops
where it can be
ingested
so ingested eaten
by insect larvae and what we're talking
about here
for a lot of crops not all is
caterpillars right like the hornworms
tomato hornworms tobacco hornworms some
of you will have seen those big fat
green worms eating your crops and i know
it's maddening i've been there
but if you spray bt insecticide
then
that's on the leaves of the crops they
get eaten or ingested by the insect
larvae
and those toxins that we talked about
are
activated
in the insect gut only in the insect gut
that the strain targets right not in the
human gut at all
activated toxins then attack gut cells
via specific
receptors
okay
so only the cells that have those
receptors that's why each strain can
target different insect groups different
insect groups have different receptors
and each strain is only going to be able
to
basically infect a cell
excuse me
each strain is only going to be able to
infect a cell
if it has that particular receptor that
that strain can bind to
so those receptors are very highly
specific but when you've got one of
these bt toxins and it's in the gut of
the insect which it targets and it has
that specific receptor there
it will bind to that receptor
and ultimately
excuse me
i'm sorry for all the coughing
it will ultimately create holes
in the gut lining of the insect so
basically if you've ever heard of like a
human having a perforated bowel that
would be holes in their in their large
intestine
this is somewhat similar right these
toxins
literally poke holes in the gut lining
of the insects
ultimately this makes the larvae feel
pretty terrible and sure
and they'll stop feeding on the crop
plant like my tomato plants for example
they'll stop feeding on the plants
really within a matter of hours
and they'll die in a couple of days
and how do they die well remember that
these holes have been poked in their gut
and so these bt spores as well as the
gut bacteria that's normally
normally held within the insect gut
both the bt spores and those normal gut
bacteria can then spill out through
those holes into the wider body cavity
of these insects
and create basically a bad infection and
that's going to kill
the
the pests right the pests that are
eating our plants
now i've said several times this is safe
for humans now i'm going to tell you all
of the different ways in which it is
safe first of all human guts lack
these receptors right here so they lack
the specific
receptors
that the bt toxins bind so there aren't
going to be any of these strains in any
of these formulations that can actually
like attack the human gut lining
also bt toxins are only activated
by proteases
it's a kind of enzyme by proteases in
the insect gut the insect gut is about a
ph 10.
and so the toxins are activated by
proteases that are only present in the
insect gut so there's not going to be
those proteases in the human gut to
activate the toxins anyway
also the bt toxins are actually degraded
or digested or
if you know the kind of super
scientific term
denatured
denatured
in the human gut remember the human gut
is about a ph2 highly acidic the insect
gut is a ph 10 pretty basic and so these
toxins a they can't get into our gut
cells because our gut cells don't have
the specific receptors they also can't
be activated because there are no
proteases around to do it
and then
even if these
bt spores did get into the human gut our
stomach acid is gonna take care of them
so quickly also bt is sensitive to
sunlight
okay
sensitive to sunlight
and it breaks down on the crops in a few
days this means if i want my tomato
plants to be safe from hornworms
i need to reapply bt you know every week
or maybe every other week if it rains a
lot i might have to reapply more
um
because bt is gonna is gonna break down
in sunlight anyway and so a lot of
farmers will be adding bt when worms are
a common problem
might reapply a couple of times
especially if it's been raining
but by the time they're harvesting the
the tomatoes or the crops or whatever by
the time they're harvesting the crop
this bt has has broken down because of
the sunlight and it's not even there
it's not even there anymore so these are
all of the reasons why it's safe for
humans and then before we end i want to
add
a cool biotech biotech application there
are gmo crop remember gmo stands for
genetically modified organism
you know scientists biological engineers
have
engineered crops like you might have
heard of
b
t
corn
is a common one
where they have actually engineered
corn plants like the crops themselves
to express
the bt toxins
and so the bt toxins are there being
produced by the corn plants themselves
and that will stop these pests
from
destroying a corn crop
and so this is a way you know farmers
that grow bt corn
they can have you know field after field
after field of corn and they don't have
to spray it every other week like i have
to spray my tomato plants with bt
insecticide because the bt toxin
it's already there naturally being
expressed by this engineered plant so so
so cool
and definitely a way to prevent loss of
huge numbers of crops
to
pests
and in a very very safe way for humans
so that's going to be it for today if
you haven't already go check out my
video on
tomato hornworms and especially the baby
tomato hornworms i just think they are
so cool so do yourself a favor see
something gross go check that one out
thanks for watching biology professor
remember to subscribe get your free
study notes at the link below
and i will see you next time thank you
so much for watching bye